[Applause]
I love yourp I love your style it's a
Onie oh is it I never grew out of it
from childhood um so wait for everybody
that hasn't seen the show I've seen it
tons we love it at our house but explain
to everybody what it is because it's
animated and live action yeah it is it's
awesome so it's a kid show obviously and
it follows my character Gabby and it
starts off in her real life bedroom and
she gets this dollhouse delivery and it
comes down a slide and inside is a
surprise that'll kind of show where the
adventure is going to take her and all
her friends for the day yeah and then
she does as you just saw in the clip
this special pinch pinch song that
transforms her into an animation and she
gets to go inside of her dollhouse as an
animation and play with all her Gabby
cats where they do crafts and and sing
songs and just learn all kinds of great
things look I'm 41 and like I watch it
too because you know you watch some with
your kids when I just I get lost in it
and then all a sudden I'll no they've
left the room and I'm like why am I
still sitting here but it's like it's
very captivating this is I hear though
your first is this your first time on a
talk show yeah first time oh my
God my kids love this show I just
figured you've done promo for it
everywhere yeah that's amazing well it
was a little weird CU a lot of the time
it was during covid so it was mostly
like Zoom interviews which not the same
thing is B it's really not the same
thing I had to interview Sher for the
first time with Co from home and I was
like Satan is winning today yeah yeah we
wanted to find out what questions kids
might have for Lyla so we asked around
it turns out a lot of them want to know
one very specific thing so let's take a
look can you show me how to shrink down
in the dollhouse just like you did you
have workers make that like make
yourself into a little doll or did you
like shrink yourself somehow how do you
shrink
y all
right what is your answer I'm sure
you've been asked this I have I've
gotten asked this a few times and it's a
tricky question it's a tricky question
don't break the wall the big reveal is I
do my pinch pinch dance and I grab P's
hand and magic magic shrinks me and I go
into the dollhouse that's the big answer
it's just magic yeah yeah I love Magic
well we have the creator of Gabby's
dollhouse in the audience everybody say
hello to Tracy Paige Johnson what's up
Tracy
so when did you know creating this
because I'm sure you have an idea in
your head like when did you know that
Lyla was Gabby oh we saw thousands of
girls and we knew immediately I quick
shout out to my co-creator Jen Tumi you
couldn't be here Jen we love
you joyous day we just knew Lyla I mean
you can see her genuine energy that
connection to camera and just you have
the you are the epitome of growth
mindset and celebrating your mistakes
and you know just such a great Mo role
model for girls and kids everywhere yeah
we did and she has a special magic trick
with her eyebrows she's very expressive
with eyebrows very
very girl people would pay for those
eyebrows those was a nice eyebrows she
comes in and like looking a camera I
mean all kids are just a perfect play
dat so she we knew immediately
how does it feel to be a part of kid
lives in that way that's kind of cool
it's it's just so unreal and it just it
makes me so happy and like because
there's so many ways like not only CU
they' like kids have experienced a lot
of instability these past years and to
to be like a part of the show that like
teaches resilience and like you know can
be like a source of stability for them
that's amazing and also just knowing
like when I was a kid like growing up I
didn't see too many girls that looked
like me on the screen screen like
whatever shows I was watching fact I can
like be that like sense of like oh my
gosh she looks like me it's just it's so
amazing and I it just I'm so grateful
that I could do that and I'm I am proud
of that like that I get to do that for
kids also on such a cool job for a high
school student
yeah well Gabby's dollhouse isn't just a
TV series Gabby's dollhouse toys from
Spin Master bring the imaginative
dollhouse world to Life with music
surprises and magic for kids to create
their own adventure this is why my kids
love it um and we're sending everyone
home with the award-winning Gabby's
perfect dollhouse Kitty Fair's Garden
tree house and the newest place at The
Gabby
C this is incredible every single place
that connects back to the dollhouse plus
thanks STS at DreamWork you're also
getting a
$150 Walmart gift card to build out your
Gabby's dollhouse world with fashion
Ving party decor and more
with it everybody you can check out
Dreamworks animation series gab's
dollhouse on
[Music]
[Applause]
Netflix thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home